the story that i'm going to tell you
this time is kind of a somber one it has
to do with the death of my
mother
monique claudette sadler in early
2000 right at the beginning of the new
millennium
and you know that happened uh more than
22 years ago this is not like a special
anniversary like the 20th or 50th or
something like that but
my my memory about that was was jogged a
few days ago
when i went into facebook and you know
how facebook has facebook memories
so it was about
the actual
day the 22nd of january when my my mom
died
and i'd posted um some pictures of
her that
her old boyfriend fran who you may know
about is sort of like a surrogate dad to
me i was lucky in that i had
several different dads in my my life
that's a whole other story with a whole
other
video
um
he had sent some some pictures of
my mom that he had on old film roles and
you know he digitized them and i was
like well this is really you know quite
cool you can get you can see who she was
and what she was like
and i saw that a couple days ago and
then i was remembering back to what it
was like in
2000 when i was
in graduate school down at southern
illinois and 29 years old i just seen my
mom
over christmas break you know which we'd
spent
at my
partly up there at her new house that
she'd she'd recently bought mortgage to
the hilt by the way in brookfield
and partly down in indiana on my
family's land you know the complex
alumni's complex
so
i didn't find out that she died the day
that she died she was down in costa rica
and she was doing this
white water rafting trip with
five other people
including her boyfriend at the time her
live-in boyfriend and
uh one of his sons
who i didn't particularly like he was
kind of a
skeevy guy
and a couple other people on the trip
and you know long story short
there were some safety problems with the
company that they were working with the
rivers were you know much
more dangerous than they had been in the
past because they were gorged with
waters that had come from you know extra
rainfall and stuff and
if things had been done right
they would not have been allowed onto
that that river and many people were
surprised that they they were um it
turned out that my mom's boyfriend
was dead set on them going out there my
mom actually opposed some you know
reservations about it and he overcame it
we also found later on that he'd torn
out pages of her diary uh probably
concealing that from from all the rest
of us
and on the trip
you know they they went on the river
and eventually
they capsized
my mother died she drowned
another person on the on the trip
actually drowned as well
her boyfriend's son broke his arm and
there they were in the middle of the
jungle
in you know on a river in costa rica in
bad conditions
with some of them half drowned some of
them some of them dead
the red cross had to go in
and
make a way
to the the actual site
strap the dead people to their backs
literally backpack them the corpses out
and then i was contacted at my i was
living in a trailer at the time in
southern illinois
and it was the middle of winter you know
very cold inside my trailer i kept the
heat around 55 degrees because it was so
badly insulated
that there wasn't much point in in
making it warmer and i remember getting
the call you know and i had at that time
it was it wasn't a cell phone it was you
know one of those
desk phones that plugged into the wall
and
hearing this person talking on the other
end saying
are you greg sadler and i was like yeah
i'm greg sadler and then this this woman
was like well i'm a i don't remember
exactly whether she was the us counsel
herself or a representative but she said
i've got some really bad news for you
and i'm going to need to get some
details from you and i was like well
what happened and then she starts
telling me
this story minus a lot of the details
that i've already mentioned to you
about my mom
drowning on a white water rafting trip
in in costa rica
and then she said well you know we've
recovered the body and um
we're having it cremated now and we'd
like to know how you would like to get
the
remains
and i was like why'd you
cremate it oh well because
you know by the time a body comes out of
the jungle after a day
and given the difference between
embalming practices in costa rica in the
united states we're not shipping a body
back
and i was actually kind of relieved
because you know dealing with uh
somebody who's been cremated
is in many respects you know
a lot simpler than dealing with a corpse
coming back that then has to be attended
to in many different ways and there was
going to be a lot of work ahead of me i
knew that already
because i was um
my mother
and and father they couldn't have kids
so they adopted me and my sister
my sister at the time was living up in
the fox cities where she'd moved to and
still lives now she was with her first
husband and she was pregnant and was not
really great at handling things anyway
so i knew it was it was going to be
falling a lot onto my shoulders and so i
said well i mean
send a
sent her remains back with her boyfriend
you know he's coming back here i'm sure
and uh the the consul said okay that's
that's fine we're gonna get you some
copies of death certificates you're
gonna need them
for everything that's coming up um
really sorry to hear about this if
there's anything i can do here's my
number et cetera et cetera and so
she mailed the death certificates to to
my my mother's house because that's
where we were going and um
my girlfriend at the time was another
graduate student uh who eventually i
married later on um and then divorced
and
you know we
she was actually living in the same park
so i went over and i told her the news
and she said well what can we do and i
said well
we have to get up to my mom's house and
we have to get up there before the
boyfriend does because when he's when he
comes back he's going to be trouble
so and we got to find you know all the
documents and and things like that and
start calling the relatives and you know
this is going to be a big thing so we
piled into her car or actually suv it
was a smaller suv with a rag top and
boy was it cold driving up there and it
was you know it this is a seven hour
drive to to get up there in good
conditions eight hours you know so
we leave in the
early
afternoon we get up there and it's you
know in the dark of winter night
and i knew where the spare key was so
you know i go in there
and were you know almost immediately met
by two little pug cats that my mom had
bought you know little
snotty nose things which i i liked you
know but i felt bad for because i had
such trouble breathing all the time
and you know i knew that they
had been cats that cat sat but that i'd
be taking care of them and we
we get up there and um
you know we started doing a little bit
of preliminary looking at documents
found the will found you know a few
other things and then started making
some some calls to my
relatives and everything starts moving
out through the grapevine you know i
come from a very large family the
lamries clan
um on my mother's side and so all of
them are getting
notified and um
you know everything starts going into
motion
um
and the next day it's like handling all
sorts of details and you know i think
maybe
it was that night that uh her boyfriend
shows up and he's got the urn and he's
all crying and oh the love of my life
and all that and i don't want to be you
know unsympathetic but he was also kind
of a grifter
and as uh my you know mom's friend fran
called him a gigolo and he had been
living with her basically
rent free for quite a long time in her
old house and in the new house he
actually tried to
claim that he had equity in the new
house and you know my family and i put
the kibosh on that very quickly she
actually put into her will because she
knew how much i disliked him that i
needed to give him some time to get his
[ __ ] together to move out
because she knew that i otherwise would
be tempted to throw him out right away
um
and you know there there was a lot of
over the next week as as we're getting
you know everything ready and organizing
a funeral mass which is a whole
different story you know because my mom
wasn't registered in the parish the
priest didn't want to do a funeral mass
for her and i was like listen you know
we're gonna have the same problem in any
other parish so you don't get to kick
this down the road you're doing a
funeral mass and uh here's what we want
to happen and he sort of gave in on that
and then we had you know the wake
afterwards
uh the visitation and that was itself
you know there's a story to be told
about that so
my mother
was at the time
the secretary of a club that she had
belonged to for a very long time the
vagabond ski club of milwaukee right
vagabonds was
basically for like middle class on up
people
who were widowed or divorced and wanted
to
make relationships or even just hook up
with with other people in similar
circumstances generally like 40 and over
i would say
and
she'd been a member of that for a long
time and they did all sorts of cool
stuff like going on skiing or going to
vacations and and you know it was good
for her um they would go dancing um
and
she was the secretary of that club at
the time so basically all the members of
the club showed up at the
visitation as did about
150 of my family as did
i don't know how many people from
tombstone pizza where she was working
she had you know been the secretary to
the general manager and then moved into
hr and had all sorts of friends there so
i would say there were at least a
hundred i would say that at least uh 1
500 people showed up at the visitation
um which means that we're all standing
in the receiving line you know wearing
i'm wearing the black suit that she had
bought me just that um
that
christmas prior i've talked about that
in another video
it was fortunate that she bought that it
was hanging for me
in the closet tailored
and i could use it you know for all of
the funeral stuff
and
we were there standing in the line for
six hours
meeting and greeting people having
people come up and shake your hand and
say i'm so sorry for your loss
people said all sorts of other crazy
[ __ ] too these vagabonders were
weird types some of them would go into
you know theological discourses about
stuff or they'd say oh she's an angel
looking down on you
and after a while i kind of lost my
patience with them and i would say yeah
for all we know she's in hell you know i
mean that's correct theology so don't
give me all this you know i didn't go on
any further because usually they'd their
eyes would bulge out then they'd move on
quickly
and um you know then we had we didn't
actually get to bury her
until much later because the ground was
frozen and we had a separate ceremony
for that i think in april
but this was just sort of the beginning
of things
and
you know my mom was
a very
active dynamic
friendly outgoing person
even manic um she she had some struggles
you know there are so there's some
mental illness in our family and some
people
are
bipolar
and she got just the polar side of that
which made her very you know popular at
parties but sometimes could make it
difficult to
carry on discussions and relate to but i
loved her and she she loved me and you
know and my sister and um
it was a great loss you know
um
she was 53 when she died now my dad was
much younger 36
but they both were robbed of a lot of
time that they could have had
and i did get to talk to her much longer
than than my dad right and we got to
have a relationship that was essentially
between adults
albeit you know an older uh adult and uh
somebody growing into adulthood not
somebody like i am today where i'm
almost
as old as she was when she died
but the loss the
absence all of that you know um
the finality
but you don't quite realize
a good bit of that while all the
arrangements are going on and
everybody's shaking your hands it's it's
months later that that comes to mind and
years later and when there's an
anniversary and you
you think about it um
and you you know you've got a lot of
choices you can celebrate somebody you
can dwell on the
pleasant memories you can argue with
them in your head about stuff that you
know should have been done differently
you can
deal with the
emptiness the loss the sorrow
which never fully goes away i would say
you can
celebrate the
achievements and the high points of
their life you can relate to them as
well
as an adult in ways that maybe you can't
as a younger adult or a kid and think oh
wow you know what must it have been like
having me as a kid you know when i look
at my own kids and i'm like boy they're
stubborn you know
um there's lots and lots of things like
that
and you know i'm i'm a bit sad and
talking about this here um and i'm not
quite sure what i'm what i'm sad about
you know
but
sometimes it's good just to register
what's what's going on with yourself
so in any case you know i was i was
reminded of
how you know i found out about my mom's
death a couple days later and then
became the person who was supposed to be
basically handling everything and
um
[Music]
what it was like
that long cold drive being in the house
meeting and greeting people talking with
people going out to the garage to have
have a beer and smoke some cigarettes
and just think about what the hell was
going on or what's going next or
any of those things
you know in her house in in a place
making decisions not for her but about
her and what her her uh
ending and legacy would be
so
those are
my reflections not particularly
organized but
seeing that facebook memory made me
think about that and then today is
probably
the
anniversary of my finding out about my
mother's death
you